à grasse un chercheur en informatique a
été écroué après la découverte d'un
serveur internet diffusant à grande
échelle des images pornographiques à
caractère pédophile
reportage yasmina farber didier beau
marc millet 29 ans ingénieur en
informatique pianoter un peu trop sur
son ordinateur en dehors de ces
recherches
et c'est son employeur le centre
national d'études des télécommunications
à sophia antipolis qui a voulu
comprendre pourquoi il avait une telle
masse de fichiers en fouillant dans
l'ordinateur
un responsable de france télécom
découvre des images particulièrement
choquant d'enfants entre 8 et 14 ans en
compagnie d'adultes
alertée la brigade de la protection des
mineurs et des policiers spécialistes
des réseaux internet vont démonter le
système il découvre le carnet d'adressé
informatique du jeune ingénieur il
aurait trouvé des serveurs pédophiles
seraient entrés en liaison avec des
amateurs pour recevoir et réexpédié des
images
après perquisition à son domicile de
mougins
les policiers découvrent sa collection
de photos des cd rom et des disques est
l'informaticien a évoqué une curiosité
passagère il a été mise en examen pour
recel et diffusion d'image
pornographique de mineurs de moins de 15
ans puis écrouée à la maison d'arrêt de
grasse le juge murciano est chargée de l
enquête la suite de ces investigations
s'attachera au décryptage de toutes les
données informatiques pour tenter de
démanteler un réseau de consommateurs
d'imagés pédophiles